Donald Trump has confirmed he is
announcing a national emergency on
Friday so bypass Congress and get
funding for a wall on the border with
Mexico we're going to be signing today
and registry national emergency and it's
a great thing to do because we have an
invasion of drugs invasion of gangs
invasion of people and it's unacceptable
live now to Kayla more pin for more on
this hi caleb welcome to the program so
how significant is this national
emergency well viewers will recall that
the united states just had its longest
government shutdown in all of its
history as Congress refused to give
funding to Donald Trump for his wall now
in order to essentially prevent another
shutdown because rather than risking
trying to battle Congress once again we
see Donald Trump declaring a national
state of emergency a national emergency
in order to secure funding for his
border wall now this is essentially
being done and there won't be another
shutdown of Congress and the president
disagreeing about what to do about it
now the response of the Democrats and of
many critics of Donald Trump has been to
declare this potentially to be a
constitutional crisis we've heard some
saying that Donald Trump himself is a
national emergency and we actually heard
Nancy Pelosi who is the Speaker of the
House a Democratic leader in Congress we
heard her floating the idea that in the
future a Democratic president might be
able to do the same thing around other
issues this is Nancy Pelosi you want to
talk about a national emergency let's
talk about today the one-year
anniversary of another manifestation of
the epidemic of gun violence in America
that's a national emergency
why don't you declare that emergency mr.
president I wish you would but a
Democratic president can do that
Democratic president can declare
emergencies as well now Donald Trump is
invoking the national emergency Act of
which is the law that has been
frequently used by many different
presidents to declare national
emergencies around many different issues
for example Bill Clinton declared six
national emergencies george w bush
declared 10 and barack obama declared 11
most of the time these national
emergencies were declared in order to
impose sanctions on a country and at
this point there are 30 national
emergencies that are still in effect and
there have been a total of 50 that have
been declared since 1976 when this law
was created now Donald Trump said in his
remarks that he fully expects this to be
challenged in court he expects us to be
appealed all the way up to the US
Supreme Court however he says that he
feels it is absolutely necessary to do
in order to deal with the problem of
violence and criminal activity near the
US border so at this point you know we
are expecting strong opposition from the
Democratic Party Democratic Party
leaders will no doubt be speaking up in
opposition to it
but Donald Trump spoke to the press
spoke to the country and said that he is
indeed taking this action to declare a
national emergency in order to build his
border wall which was a central aspect
of his presidential campaign
you